trying not to drool over sutton it's
getting embarrassing we are very excited
that she is here she is a two-time tony
award winner she's back on broadway
starring in the music man it's the
classic musical first premiered back in
1957.
it's about a charismatic con man
professor harrell hill is his name
played by a great hugh jackman in the
revival so he arrives in river city iowa
and he convinces the town that he's
starting a boys band but listen to this
he doesn't know how to play music what
he tells them if they want their kids to
join the band they need to buy
instruments and uniforms from him
so sutton foster she plays mary and
madame librarian who takes some
convincing but eventually uh oh falls in
love with him
was
[Music]
no
[Music]
i never
heard it at all
[Music]
will you people please shut up tony's
like i'm trying to ruining a good
performance sutton foster welcome
welcome i was there opening night and
wrote g at the end did you hear me going
yes oh my goodness you remember
that show is so much fun and so you
haven't been back on broadway for a
couple of years now how's it feel up
there on the stage with you and hugh
jackman together it's been a dream truly
and especially after these last couple
years and even now during such
of such uncertainty should we say um i
just feel
incredibly grateful and it's so so
joyful an amazing company hugh is a
dream and having the time of my life
always a dream and the kids that are in
the show we were talking you know before
we went on the air you said there's
something different about working with
kids
yes i mean and there's
better yes it does and there's 21
broadway debuts in our cast which is
remarkable it and that we have a cast of
about 46. so about half of our cast is
making their broadway debut and um there
is there's something really powerful and
beautiful about working with kids i
think it brings out uh the best and
everything do you remember your broadway
debut
yes i felt like yeah i was 21
i made my broadway debut in a revival of
greece uh this was many
years ago but yeah it was a dream come
true you know you work your whole life
for
and it's it for me it was something i
just didn't even know was possible and
yeah i will i will never forget it so 21
debuts does that mean you get 21 knocks
on the door looking for advice
what do you tell them i do you know what
i'm i'm i'm a mom i have a five-year-old
daughter
so my mom gene has been ignited so i do
feel like a bit of a mama bear to a lot
of these kids um
and lately all the a lot of the kids are
just telling me about um like dates and
so they're going i'm getting more advice
i'm giving more advice about that or
just living vicariously through them you
know
you and hugh jackman have unbelievable
chemistry uh on stage and i heard that
uh as part of your pre-show ritual you
guys sit down on the floor on a rug
in one of your dressing rooms and share
coffee or a drink or something uh what
what's the purpose of all that how does
that work we call it carpet chat
well you know one of the best things
that happened is because of covid when
we were in rehearsals we ended up
sharing a like a like a room at the
rehearsal space and because we were they
were trying to keep everything you know
safe and and we just we would have a
check-in every day and we became just
really close and and then when we moved
to the theater we each had our own
dressing rooms and we were like wait a
minute i'm going to miss you and so we
come together for about a half hour
before every show every show yeah
together it's pretty cool and we just
sort of what do you talk about oh
everything you know and it's like um
so because so often i think in shows you
feel uh especially when you're playing a
leading role and you're sort of you kind
of feel like you're on your own and and
we've just kind of really bonded and
you're kind of this little pair and uh
yes like the greatest thing that's come
out of this whole experience is that i
have a new friend well it it translates
to the stage because you guys have
amazing chemistry together and i was at
a performance last night where you know
you guys were having fun with each other
there was you know um 30 seconds of
where you broke character i don't know
what you're talking about looking at you
and laughing and then you were like
looking at him so weird i really i can't
recall um no i blame hugh jackman no
he's a devil you know he's he always has
like a little twinkle in his eye but
there there is a there's a lot of um
what what what spontaneity
unpredictability yeah it's it's it's a
it's it's really fun there's a lot of
playfulness and
yeah and your your daughter is five and
she's gotten to see you for the first
time on broadway too does it make a
difference when she's in the audience
what's that moment like for you because
she was there oh yeah yeah
i love her pigtails emily yes well okay
so
even before i was cast in the music man
uh every night
my husband and i sing good night my
someone to her even though i didn't know
the lyrics so we it's all like we didn't
but that's what we always we sing to her
every single night so the first time she
saw the show when i started to sing good
night by someone in the show i was like
really
like overcome but then the song that
really surprised me was tilde was you
because
that every single lyric like
it was suddenly it became about her like
i i didn't know what love was until
there was her that's beautiful and and
your husband has a connection to the
music man we have a picture i think you
posted on your instagram because i think
like a lot of people in this country
we've all been in productions of music
man in high school or in elementary
school we haven't all vlad
correction we haven't all elementary
school um and so and he was as well so
he already knew all the songs yeah yeah
so my husband was cast as mayor shin in
his high school he was a senior in high
school and although he wanted to play
harold hill so you know but he um so he
knew the show better than i did
so when i was immediate when i was
approached about playing marion he was
like i got i got tips
[Laughter]
i'm sure that was the voice he used too
because that's how women always imagine
how guys talk of
course
and you did seven seasons and then
younger too that's right yes i'm sorry i
was younger did you miss it
i do it was seven years of my life you
know it was like seven amazing years and
i just uh
yeah i couldn't have asked for a better
experience on in a television show with
a more incredible cast and i loved
playing liza miller and it was it was it
was awesome so what's your dream now
because you said as a little girl you
didn't know you could do this that this
was a job being on broadway what's your
dream now for yourself i really want to
have a great garden this year i'm really
into gardening
i love it
i thought you're into crafting
that too oh yeah no anything that i can
create so yeah i'm always constantly
creating and but right now i really if
anyone has any good gardening tips
that's my that's my uh i want to grow
some killer tomatoes well listen she had
two shows yesterday guys you have
another show today and look at you
looking so lovely i love the shoes i
love the dress thank you thank you we
should tell people that the
the the reactions to this show are just
over the moon
like if all of america could somehow
watch this together we'd be a better
country yeah somebody said bring your
kids to the show i guarantee they'll
leave there being theater lovers of the
theater yeah which is wonderful although
i heard your daughter was still
processing the performance has she come
around to an opinion yet
she well she did want to see it before
opening night just to make sure she
liked it
so because i invited her to opening so
she came in previews and she was like i
like i'll come but it's gonna make you
feel good though sudden that people feel
this way about this show doesn't it it's
incredible yeah and i always think about
that every single night when i do when i
do a show i'm like oh there's a little
kid out there that maybe this will
ignite something in them especially
because there are little kids on stage
we were saying that seeing those little
children they're incredibly diverse um
and they are so talented i mean these
kids are dancing as good as you and you
i mean it's insane
[Laughter]
this is great for new york people should
buy their tickets now like go online and
they're going fast well it's the highest
selling or the biggest grossing broadway
show right now we're supposed to in this
interview a minute and 30 seconds ago
but we did we didn't want to stop
talking to you they're actually they're
pretty calm about it so you're doing
great
what else do we want to talk about the
music man it's on broadway right now at
the winter garden theater and we'll be
right back